Daishoubu Hime char Haaaaaahh
goo It's
over Oh yeah
yeah It's so small  Then
I'm different from you humans
Ah, the existence that causes all kinds of disasters and spreads horns,
Ainu language gunpowder burns
Reporter Maki ni
Eh
[Music]
It's okay to get out of the kneading on chain kitchen days
Nakai no 4  It was my sister who was able to use it
none
day The power of those in the demon world We human beings can understand
it well Come on, I'm sure I've been through a lot more than I can imagine
Cigar me sweets  I
shouldn't have been surprised I should have done
this from the beginning, so I'll
have you disappear here
And from tomorrow,
it's already hard to come up with ideas
Hime-chan is a hard worker, but
if you try 100
times  Please feel
free to talk to me anytime.